so this is the beginning of a fun day
and it is a particular pleasure to start
with mark entries and who is one of my
personal heroes and our cover boy this
this month mark and and I have had first
met him 18 years ago when he was a baby
faced a recent graduate of the
University of Illinois and I had just
started Netscape had invented the modern
reco invented the modern browser and you
know one of the most striking things in
this in his first meeting with him which
is really just I you know understand the
whole we were trying to figure out the
basic web was was that although mark was
interested in the in the technology and
the software and all that he immediately
was talking about global economics about
about the effect on innovation on social
impact and all that and it was just sort
of it was so unexpected
that's what at this I think the time you
were 22
I think this 22 year old you know a
software engineer right out of school
was thinking about the hugest impact of
the web and that I think set the tone
for Mark's career there was you know one
of the first to think of the browser is
an operating system which we now think
of Chrome OS and beyond one of the first
to consider the impact of the cloud to
use the term loud Club which became
Opsware one of the first to get into
social and then most recently after he
started the venture capital firm the
theory of the software will eat the
world which we'll talk more about which
i think is absolutely mind-blowing and
and probably the right way to think
about software that sort of combination
of feet on the ground technology and and
almost sort of a philosopher king of the
thought about the the broad implications
is is is is why mark is is it here i'm
and here so welcome thanks I wanted to
to start with we have a bunch of things
to talk about and by the way questions
should you can tweet it to us a hashtag
wired biz con so I'll be seeing that
will go about 20 minutes here and then
10 minutes
for four questions both online and in
the audience but let's just start with
in the whole notion of we'll get to this
or technology transport start to the
whole notion of the of the financial
markets at the moment the bubble the
notion that we're in a bubble now marks
on several boards that including
Facebook so we can't talk about Facebook
per se but the over buddy as a venture
capitalist the notion you know this
question must come up all the time are
we in the bubble and you know when you
see some Instagram selling for a billion
dollars with no revenues one has to ask
how do these valuations come out come
about and how do you justify them so I
know you can't talk about that in
particular but as a VC when you look at
valuations right now how do you do the
math and come up with something you can
justify sure so I should start by saying
you know can hashtag conflict of
interest I am you know I'm invested in a
lot of these companies so that's
obviously to my benefit if we're not a
bubble but on the other hand I'm
investing because I don't think we're in
a bubble
so maybe the the various conflicts
balance themselves out so I as you said
I can't I can't talk about Facebook I
can't talk about Instagram so I'll leave
that to other people
but let's pose a hypothetical case of
let's say Google decides to buy
vidi-vidi you guys social news new
social video some people saying
histogram for video so social video
company's a very social cam a couple
other companies they've been growing
very quickly the last few weeks on sort
of mobile mobile social video or even to
make it even even even even better for
me let's say it's you know moogle buying
you know diddy just to take it
completely into the realm of the
hypothetical so big established
technology franchise company like google
that decides it wants to own you know
kind of a hot new sort of social viral
thing you know I think there's a couple
things in terms of how these things
could value that I think makes a lot of
sense for the acquire in the case of
like for in the hypothetical case of a
Google at Google where to do that one is
they're gonna be looking not so much at
how very modifies us but how Google
would be able to monetize vide which by
the way is the exact logic by which
Google bought YouTube which is one of
the great deals of of all time and so
it's not so much the actual money that
the startup is making today it's what
the large company can actually do once
they have it in terms of monetization
and large companies always have very
detailed internal models I mean I see
this on you know the other boards I'm on
when you do
you always have very complex detailed
models based on your existing business
that show what you're gonna be able to
do with the acquired company Yahoo had a
very similar model when they went to buy
Facebook for a billion dollars six or
seven years ago which in retrospect
would have been a very good deal had
Yahoo been able to get it closed so
that's one is what could be acquired or
do with it the other is you know to the
extent that acquire the extent for
example that somebody like Google thinks
that social is a is a is a problem and
something that needs to be solved and is
a potential threat to the core business
then what percentage of the acquirers
market cap might they be willing to
spend to buy the insurance policy to buy
basically to basically buy the insurgent
you know sort of like you know so you
know bad metaphor but you know in the
u.s. goes into Afghanistan there's a
certain amount of money will pay to like
to buy off the Taliban and when a large
company buys a start-up it's often kind
of the same thing of like there's a
certain amount of money will pay in
order to make sure that we capture
what's about to happen as opposed to
having it happen to us and so again
there's a strategic value to you know to
these things made a lot of cases that
the drives what happens and and I would
say you know the strategic value you
know it's always a hypothetical at the
time but then you look at lots of these
examples you know of companies that
could have bought you know the companies
that ultimately disrupted them and
didn't do it and so you know you've got
and then you see these companies like
whether it's Kodak or borders or
whatever they get eaten by software and
go down in flames yeah it's like well if
they could travel back in time if they
could spend one percent or ten percent
of their market cap to basically buy the
insurgents before things got too far do
you have some that probably would have
been a good idea do you have some
examples that come to mind of companies
that should have bought but didn't well
I mean there's a whole bunch of examples
I mean probably the one in the market
right now this most dramatic to watch
well the two that are most dramatic to
watch right now are Nokia and RIM right
both of which in retrospect about five
years ago I mean it needed a modern
operating system and didn't have one and
didn't buy one and if they had in either
of those cases you know things might
have turned out very differently so who
could they have bought it oh they could
have been so hope I mean they could have
bought palme they could have bought at
one point they could about it I mean
Google bought Android right at a point
when they could have bought Android and
there been lots of other people running
around trying to do you know smartphone
OS is you know you know back then so
there are always new teams and people
trying to do this today it's probably
too late but at the time it probably
would've been a good idea and at the
time they probably would have gotten
criticized for overpaying because right
at the time it would have said well you
know the smartphone market is tiny you
know why would you ever spend any money
on this well because as they say shift
happens well so exactly so you but you
describe a situation where you're buying
complex technology you need complex
technology you
you failed to develop the complex
technology yourself so you buy the
complex technology whereas in the other
in the previous instances presumably the
instagrams are the the apps that they
were their equivalents are the
technology is not terribly complex what
you're buying is in some sense the user
base is that wrong yeah so I disagree
with it depends it depends what you mean
by technology to become tonyia for a
second so I think people really
underestimate the technology behind some
of these things and especially for some
reason the communications the community
the communications advances tend to get
criticized for not being very sort of
technology heavy and I think it's very
unfair you know you always say well you
know actually my friend Peter Thiel and
I argue about this all the time is he
you know he always says well you know
you know it's a Twitter doesn't count as
dialogical innovation you know compared
to the you know compared to go into the
moon and my argument is you know I'd
much rather have Twitter than you know
than the moon landing you know the moon
landing you know 20 guys were able to go
to the moon you know it turned out there
was nothing there you know Twitter
you've got five billion people who are
gonna be able to communicate with each
other in a much better way you know I
think for an important standpoint these
communications things are actually very
important number two the technology
actually turns out to be complex and and
in building a system that's able to
handle millions and ultimately billions
of people communicating in real-time
being able to wire into the basic
technology what the patterns of user
behavior are gonna be so the whole thing
kind of holds together and people behave
the right way
scaling a system like that and then
having all the capabilities that end up
surrounding a system like they have the
API is you know the platform
capabilities and so forth and getting it
wired into thousands of applications you
know these tend to be very very big deep
technology efforts you know analogous in
a lot of ways to what AT&T did once upon
a time when they built the telephone
system so it's the same kind of thing
and so I think there's a lot more
technology the other thing I'd say as
people get distracted there's a lot of
criticism right now you know we see this
with companies you know companies weird
best in companies in a Foursquare even
even Facebook and Twitter themselves you
know or Instagram or vidi or Socialcam
these companies where they say well it's
just an app right it's just gonna happen
like there's you know there's a hundred
thousand apps in the App Store and so
what can i me want to be worth and it's
like well an individual app like itself
may not be worth much but the app
augmented by the backend right by all of
the capabilities and the network and all
these other things that we're talking
about you know the what the user
actually sees for a lot of the really
important technologies what the user
really sees is a very small fraction of
the actual value a lot of the value is
embedded in the back-end systems and
then the team that's been able to wire
that
together and that's the case for a lot
of these companies your point is that
although the engineers may say we could
build rather than Buy in fact it's
harder than they think it's much yeah
yeah so bill verses bias typically
especially a big companies is typically
much harder to build internally than
people thinking well so the other thing
right the other thing that big companies
big companies again big companies
criticized for doing acquisitions but a
big part of what big companies are able
to do through acquisitions especially in
our industry is they're able to
basically let the darwinian free market
figure out what new things are gonna
work and what things aren't right so so
it's always kind of it's always
criticism sort of in retrospect saying
well you know such-and-such big company
should have done that thing internally
right well it's like they wouldn't have
known up front nobody knew that that
thing was the thing that was gonna work
it's that thing plus the thousand other
things that people tried that failed
right and so there's no big company
that's gonna try all the experiments of
the open market of the free markets
gonna be able to do and a big part of
what venture capital does this basically
funds all those experiments and then I
think big companies get to take
advantage of the darwinian startup
environment to basically cherry-pick the
best of the bunch in a lot of cases and
be able to fold them in so you don't
believe we're in a bubble you believe
these valuations are justified well I
just think I think number one I think
objectively it's hard to say we're in a
bubble in technology generally when
technology stocks are trading at a
30-year low relative to industrials
right so we're 15 years we're now 15
years of flat stock market returns
overall and we're at a 30-year low of
tech stocks multiples relative to
industrials so if we're in a bubble it's
the weirdest bubble I've ever seen where
everybody hates everything right
everybody's just in like a foul mood and
like any of you can see this with these
new tech companies these new connect
companies the last you know year you
know a bunch of Internet companies gone
public and if you check their stocks
lately like they just you know they've
like generally like hard-nosed straight
into the ground like that's a weird
bubble the public markets and yet more
and more transactions are happening the
private markets so then you have this
very interesting phenomenon where you
have these these new businesses in the
private markets some of which are you
know billion dollar plus revenue
companies some of which have been
created literally in two or three years
some of which don't have revenue yet but
people think they're gonna have a lot of
revenue and then you've got this very
interesting phenomenon I've you've got
public market investors like mutual
funds and hedge funds that are crossing
over basically buying these stakes in
these late stage companies which is
where a lot of the bubble criticisms
where a lot of evaluations come from
that causes people to just say bubble
well so the problem is you look at it
from the perspective of a public market
investor like say 15 years of flat stock
market returns which is really kind of
extraordinary if you think about it like
15 years so just like basically nothing
in the stock market number one number
two over that time period it's gotten
much harder for companies to go public
because of all the new regulations the
result of that has been that if you
correcting for GDP growth the number of
public companies in the market today and
the stock market today the number of
public companies is half of what it was
ten years ago right and so what's
happening is the public term is d equity
Seng so the public stock market is d
equit izing so more and more of the
actual interesting economic activities
happening on the private side now if
these companies you know years ago all
these private companies would long since
have been public I mean when I came up
you took these companies public you know
16 months after you know after you start
them and I think you had that both the
first and the second the fastest IPO in
the second fastest IPO but we took me oh
so we took in SK public as an example on
a 20 million dollar revenue quarter
which you know at the time was like a
decent like that was a decent size to go
these days you would never do that it's
just it's way too hard and expensive and
there's all kinds of issues involved in
doing that and so so what's happened is
basically the opportunities for if
you're a public investor and you want to
invest in growth the opportunities to
invest in growth of the public side are
just vanishing they're just not there
and so they've shifted to the private
side so you know we'll see what happens
things like the JOBS Act are gonna you
know are basically a counter trend and
so hopefully you know we start to get
regulatory reform maybe we'll start to
get more IPOs but right now if you have
to go in the public market and investing
growth it's actually very hard to find
things to investor and so I think that's
a you know we'll see I don't think that
indicates bubble I just think that
indicates you know there's just
strangeness in the way that the markets
are behaving we're talking about a small
number of companies we're talking about
a small number of investors you know to
me none of that says bubble that just it
just is what it is so as those
valuations go up does your job as a VC
get harder or easier I mean obviously
your exits get better but your your the
valuations of the initial valuations or
presumably there's an expectation
there'll be higher as well well we'll
see if the exits get better I mean you
know it's all theory until they go
public or get sold until then it's all
just own numbers in a piece of paper you
know generally easy I mean generally the
more late stage capital that's available
the better life is for VCS and that
these companies can get funded on
generally that's good you know so you
know on average is good but you know
it'd be better it would be better if we
had a well-functioning public market
like we used to yeah that would be
proven you mentioned the JOBS Act which
is the the Obama administration's
initiative to encourage crowdfunding and
sort of smaller ability for for smaller
investors to get involved
we're gonna be talking to Kickstarter
later on today and this is not exactly
it's not equity investment but it is an
opportunity for people to essentially
fund small companies by pre-ordering
products and in a sense when you look at
Kickstarter in particular do you see
this as a competition for venture
capital or in some sense you know maybe
collaboration with venture capital I
mean how does that fit into your
ecosystem well as of right now
Kickstarter is very interesting as of
right now Kickstarter can either be used
for a non-profit projects or for-profit
projects it's actually by policy it's
actually very interesting it only gets
used for things that are somewhere in
the middle and I wasn't sure for a long
time whether there was anything in the
middle but actually so technically what
your starter gets used for a sort of
artistic projects creative projects well
I mean the the poster child of the
moment is pebble this they're a
SmartWatch that just raised or still
it'll raise monies but above seven
million dollars now that's a for-profit
entity it's it is becoming a farmer
they're they were attempting to raise
money for a company and they might have
my understanding of the stories they
were having a hard time raising money
for a company so they decided to
basically see if the community wanted to
fund it right but I'm just saying like
under Kickstarter's policy that
qualifies as a creative project not as a
for-profit project now it's put in to
your point though it's pushing the
envelope I mean obviously in my mind
obviously Kickstarter or something like
Kickstarter should exist for for-profit
projects something like it should exist
for nonprofit projects clearly there's
tremendous pent up clearly there's
tremendous amount of pent up user demand
you know consumer demand to be able to
participate in you know basically voting
with one's dollars with one's wallet you
know for things that one wants to see
exist I think that's a that's a great
concept so the answer the question is
the big thing Kickstarter is doing right
now in a case like pebble is a signal
it's signaling demand like it's
signaling real tangible demand before
the company even gets funded right which
is something that has not been I mean
the you know in the old days in the old
days the the precedent for this in the
old days was you know if I were if I was
a if I wrote books for a living and I
wanted to you know write a new book I
didn't know if there was demand for it
right I put a classified ad you know in
the back of the New Yorker stuff laying
on the back of Wired and I'd say you
know if you want those books and you
know 1995 plus shipping an handling.you
such an address if enough people sent
checks I would write the book right very
quickly exactly as quickly as possible
you know people some of our
entrepreneurs experiment that way on
sort of on on Google answer you might
Google ads for a product that doesn't
exist yet you see if people click
through so
Kickstarter is like the next advance on
that front it's sort of predicting
demand by
actually proving that there's demand as
opposed to just hypothesizing about it
so I think it's a great thing so you
would you would say when you look at a
company it has a successful Kickstarter
you know project it's de-risked it oh
yeah some degree never you but it's also
diminished their need for you and
personally improve their increase their
sense of their own valuation yeah well
so this is but this is sort of the
nature of venture capital is you're
gonna you know if you're a venture
capital investor you're optimizing for
valuation you definitely want to invest
in these things before they prove the
direct demand on the other hand there
are a lot of things especially the
really disruptive really new ideas that
you know are hard to think about ahead
of time you know a lot of the times
those companies have trouble raising
money and when they have trouble raising
money is because they can't prove the
demand so I think that's a I think
that's a net plus so you and so if a
pebble or something like that comes to
and they say look you know we had this
incredible you know run but we now need
to ramp up our production processes by
some you know far faster than we
realized we're not gonna do it simply on
pre-orders alone that would be an
appealing oh absolutely
yeah very much so no yes which actually
takes me to to the the notion of
internet meets hardware I mean so pebble
is let's say an example of the Internet
of Things which is to say increasingly
these devices on our bodies and around
our houses that have intelligent sensors
wireless that are connected to the
Internet in various ways and this to end
this you know this takes me a little bit
to your thesis of software eats
everything and this is this notion that
more and more what we're contrition aliy
Hardware functions become software
functions the E and there's an app for
that today they kind of they they kind
of get subsumed into general-purpose
computing platforms so on one hand we
see sort of a spread of single purpose
hardware devices that are connected to
the Internet and the other we see the
apt notion of all those of the devices
being sucked into a singular device like
like a like a phone or an iPad do you
see these being in competition or is
this all part of your your thesis well I
think the big thing that's happening is
a much larger percentage of the IP and
the value add in a consumer electronics
device whatever that is this is
special-purpose for general-purpose the
percentage of IP or value-add or kind of
economic value or innovation or
technology or whatever you wanna call it
in that thing the percentage of that
that software is rising very quickly my
favorite example of this is the iPhone
itself iPhone itself is interesting so
people say well iPhone you know a phone
is a great example of how manufacturing
outside the US manufacturers bad phone
is built in China in fact China in
people talked about the trade deficit
all the time right so China gets full
credit for ship for it in the in the in
their in their trade numbers for the
production of the iPhone in the process
of building and shipping into the US
right in practice though right this is a
little line design in California in
practice the vast majority of the IP in
the iPhone right which is to say all of
the actual to algae innovation as well
as all the actual dollars of profit that
result of course are created by
companies not in China created by Apple
and created by the ecosystem of app
developers which for the most part or
not in China created by the chip
designers you know companies like
Broadcom and Qualcomm and others that
are very us-based companies so the vast
majority of the actual IP and economic
value of the iPhone is not attributable
to China it's attributable to the United
States it's actually and this all warps
all the trade numbers this causes us to
think we have much bigger trade deficit
than we do because trying to get full
credit for that and their trade numbers
whereas they shouldn't they should
really only get credit for the small
percentage of the value that is
attributable to you know to actually
putting the thing together and so that
that's kind of a case study I think of
what's happening across consumer
electronics and this is a big part of
the thesis that I have which is I think
that a lot of the consumer electronics
industry is actually going to move back
to the United States now if not in the
manufacturing part then certainly in all
the design and software and network
services and all of the sort of actual
value and all the interesting
capabilities to get built around it
right not completely but there's a big
counter trend happening in that
direction and so what does that do to
the American economy it's just
tremendously positive it's a huge it's a
very very positive thing because he's a
very big markets and he's a very big
opportunity for these companies but we
have a whole ecosystem in the United
States of chip makers and you know
people to make all the wireless you know
the radios and people who make all the
software and the apps and everything and
all the network services you know
Facebook and Google and all these
companies are in the US and they now get
to express what they do through more and
more different kinds of hardware so I
think it's very exciting and then I
think you you you get this sort of you
know the great debate that happens if
like as a special purpose hardware or
general purpose hardware I think that's
just a timing and staging issue and I
think that you know for a long time you
know took a long time for a lot of
things to collapse into the smartphone
and now they have there's this sort of
this new generation I'm wearing the my
favorite my jaw bone jaw bones up
bracelet more than like the Nike feel
the Nike yeah so you know battle and
you know I think you know right now
these are these are you know sort of
functional appliances or sort of you
know fixed function appliances you know
I think these are gonna become
general-purpose computing platforms yeah
and then I you know I think there's
gonna be a variety of new kinds of
general-purpose computing platforms
these things are gonna have apps stores
and they're gonna have all kinds of
downloadable functionality we do have
Nike on actually later later in the day
and you know just watching their at
their own company I mean they they you
know originally started these little
sensors in your shoes and then
increasingly and then watches with GPS
increasing these became smartphone
functions but then you realize he didn't
necessarily wanna carry the phone
throughout the life and it was right
your day and so some of them the bits
that need to be on your body are on your
body the beats that can be on the phone
are on the phone and the I agree we get
the serve balance between the two the
question you must get all the time and
both as a VC and and and a technology
and leaders is what's the next big thing
and when you're looking at particular at
your investing philosophy and weight
where you're looking for the next big
ideas can you describe any sectors or
thesis that you follow well the main
thing we try to do is to not have any
theses so the main thing we try to do is
to is to be as opportunistic as possible
so my experience is when the next you
know when the next Mark Zuckerberg walks
in the room it tells you he's gonna
build Facebook you know the really
radical ideas are out of left field like
they're either it's actually really
funny they're either ideas that nobody's
thought of before in which case that you
just don't know how to wrap your head
around them at all or like in the case
actually about Facebook and Google their
ideas that actually 35 other companies
tried before and didn't succeed on and
then you get that you know the kid who
says up but I'm gonna be the one who
makes it work and then it turns out
they're right and so you wanna it's very
easy easy to be too early it's very easy
to be too latest very early to not take
these things seriously when they first
appear and so I find having too many
theories upfront and just like rules out
all the disruption you know because if
you could if you can put a framework
around it then it's probably not
disruptive you know at least at the time
that a venture capitalist is supposed to
be saying it so we try really hard to
not basically you know smoke you know
smoke exhaust you know on that kind of
thing that said we can't help ourselves
we have 18,000 theories and we spend all
day talking about this stuff so you know
I'll float a couple you know one is you
know the thing that's under hyped you
know John doar used to say the Internet
is under hyped you know the things under
hype you know
the smartphone revolution is underhyped
we have never lived through an
opportunity in our industry to put a
computer in the pocket of five billion
people there's never been anything even
remotely close to it and this is why I
get all fired up on all these new
communication technologies and all these
new social networks and everything the
opportunity to wire the planet I mean
you know pcs only ever got to some
number of hundreds of millions of people
the smartphone is gonna take you know
more people now have mobile phones and
have access to running water right and
those things are all fall all phones are
gonna be smartphones and so everybody's
gonna have a general-purpose computer in
their pocket everybody's gonna have full
access to the Internet everybody's gonna
have full access to search engines and
social networks and online education and
all these things and we've it's so easy
to underestimate this we've just we've
never had anything like that before in
history of the planet and so that has to
be the really really big one that sort
of the story of our time
can you describe one of those at left
field opportunities that came in your
office recently that you investment in
oh well okay my favorite one so my
favorite Lytro is our new camera company
you only talk about the ones that have
launched we got a bunch that haven't
launched yet but the light roll launched
recently so Lytro so we backed a new
camera company and if you had asked me
when you started our venture capital
firm in 2009 are we gonna back into
camera company right well Kodak is in
the process of going out of business I
would have said you're out of your mind
like that's a crazy idea and this guy
walks in whren walks in and he spent 15
years of Stanford in the computer
science program building this new
technology called light-filled
photography right which basically is the
first fundamental advance of photography
since the invention of photography right
it's a much bigger advance than digital
no switch to analog to digital and so
concept of light-filled photography is
he's got basically he captures all the
three-dimensional light rays in a scene
as opposed to just the two-dimensional
rays that it happened to hit the camera
lens and so you you're able you take one
photo and then you capture all
conceivable all possible 2d photos that
could be rendered of that scene and you
can re render at any point you want so
you can refocus the image after the fact
you can relight the image after the fact
you can change the perspective there's
all these just magical things you can do
and it's really the sort of combination
of photography and computer graphics
kind of bringing together a ton of us
happen in Hollywood the last 20 years
bringing together what happens in the
real world with what you can do in on
computers and you know at Stanford they
built one of these things and it was a
wall you know it was a literally a wall
of cameras it was like a 15 by 15 foot
wall cameras cost you know millions of
dollars to build this thing he figured
out how to put the thing on a chip right
you know story of our of our industry
and then he went out and partnered with
the former chief technology officer and
co-founder of Sultan silicon graphics
which of course was the leading company
in 3d graphics 20 years ago that created
kind of you know Jurassic Park and then
all these you know these all these great
3d draft 3d graphics we see all around
us today and so they've just built
absolutely breakthrough you know
photographer first camera and it's just
absolutely marvelous you know the
current one is fairly low resolution so
people are still trying to figure out
what to do with it you know the next
version they ship is gonna be super high
resolution you're gonna be able to do
basically anything to do with the
conventional camera and I just you know
and we'll see I think it's gonna do very
well I can tell you we never would have
predicted we back a camera company yeah
I mean we just we pick up the newspaper
and Kodak goes bankrupt and it's like
you don't know whether to laugh or cry
but you know yeah let me ask one more
question before we turn to the the
questions from the audience in Twitter
so you can just describe that the
smartphone revolution has been under
hyped and that there's gonna be you know
it can a supercomputer in the pocket and
all phone's gonna be smartphones instead
or they you know typically smartphones
the one thing we know is that is that
the the phone's advanced faster than the
networks so the gating factor seems to
be you know the carriers and all that
especially outside of developed world
that seems to be an argument for the app
future and yet and you know and and now
with with cards on the table my my my
argument that there's a risk of the open
web going going the way at the close
gardens of apps and you know and and you
know the iTunes world the Apple world
the Facebook world etc in part because
consumers want the ease of use of this
kind of you know controlled experience
running counter to everything that you
invented with the you know the original
web how do you square the to the notion
that a smart phones are going to win and
be the belief or hope that the open web
where is gonna win this gonna be another
cover well this is I guess I'm asking
you know for the web is dead part it
will or is it going to be that that you
know html5 Rises and and and solves this
problem and keeps open and utility and
wait work out yeah so I think you I
think you nearly you nailed the app
phenomenon but so yes that the limiter
is the networks I mean the good news of
the networks is Wi-Fi is kind of the
outlet and so actually it's really funny
if you talk to the carrier's two or
three years ago they would have said
Wi-Fi is a big competitor and they talk
to you talk to them today and they're
like Wi-Fi is the great Savior right
like they're all hoping for a massive
Wi-Fi proliferation because the more
Wi-Fi there are in offices and homes the
less the 3G 4G networks get you
meltdown so it so it's it's so it's not
an absolute it's not like we're facing
absolutely network meltdown although
there there are challenges but yeah so
apps apps are a are a are clearly I mean
that lots of people have lots of reasons
for doing app so one of the big reasons
is because you get much more logic
running locally on the machine so you're
able to in theory cut the cut the
bandwidth use it's great it's not I
don't think it slowing down the web at
all I don't think it's lined on the web
at all I don't think it's lined on the
mobile web at all the browsers on modern
smartphones are state-of-the-art and if
they weren't stated here I'm not sure
anybody would want those phones so for
all of everything Apple and Google are
doing to foster an app ecosystem the you
know Safari and chrome you know these
Android browser or top Mouse browsers
there's actually quite a few third-party
browsers now mobile phones that are
doing very well and I think you know
look users like apps users like games
users love the web you know and so I
think it's much more of an aunt than it
is an or in a world of infinite network
bandwidth I think you'd you'd go
completely do a web model in the long
run we won't be there for a while
there's a lot of smart people working on
that or working on you know much higher
levels of bandwidth there's actually you
know big efforts underway at the FCC you
know to release a lot more bandwidth
into the wild you know to solve some of
this so we'll see what over five or ten
years I think the situation will change
a lot of the bandwidth front but for now
at least I think they'll really coexist
and we see companies doing both we see
variations on everything we see
companies building apps that contain
browsers right now we see companies
building browser-based
apps that basically look like their
desktop apps you know because they're
advanced users of html5 and it's just
it's kind of just an implementation
detail and you're bullish on html5 yeah
of course yeah so I'm let me turn now to
questions from the audience and what
we'd like to do that we have someone on
Twitter which will all be which will be
queued up momentarily but also we have
microphones moving around so there's one
in the back etc so let's start here I
see a question up here in the front
please please identify yourself Lori
fina
we met when you were starting mosaic in
any case and I was at the Electronic
Frontier Foundation so you mentioned
that we have an interesting disconnect
between broadband speeds
it just was released that Akamai said
that last quarter versus this quarter
speeds are 14% down globally and yet we
have a incredible increase in
smartphones
but the the thing that we talk about or
we don't talk about is the lack of
storage on smartphones and the
dependence on centralized clouds for
delivering apps and the storage becomes
the limiting factor or the broadband is
exercised a great deal because of the
lack of storage at the at the point
where people are using the apps what are
your thoughts on storage as one of the
third components here yeah I mean I
think that these these are very powerful
computers and so I think that they're
gonna end up with a lot of storage I
think the value of a lot of the apps
though is in the connectivity to the
network I mean I think goes back to kind
of what I said before about things like
Foursquare and Twitter and all these
things is you know the app is kind of
the tip of the iceberg of what the what
a lot of these things do it's actually
being connected to the world you know
that makes a big difference I mean you
know do we compete your app without
being able to get to Wikipedia is no fun
the Twitter app without being able to
get to Twitter is no fun and so you know
the network connectivity the smartphone
without the network connectivity that's
not it's not very interesting and so
clearly I think you need the network on
that and the phone to evolve in parallel
terrific take another question over here
please yeah hello my name is Joshua
Rockoff I helped invent Magento just a
question from on an open source to a
for-profit model you obviously started
with Mozilla Netscape and successfully
migrated that to a for-profit model how
did you maintain that openness and
community aspect of it while still
making money off of it well there's the
old days and then there's the new days
so in the old days you tried to come up
with a split business model is it sort
of the open source business model where
you so we basically have for example in
the early days of the browser with both
mosaic and Netscape we had split
licenses right so you had academic
nonprofit and in sort of individual
users could use something for free and
then businesses had to pay and you know
my sequel tried a different variation of
that model and right had tried a
different variation in that model these
days things have changed a lot right the
modern browser business model is the
browser is free and it's paid for by
primarily by search subsidies and so
like the Firefox as an example you know
actually makes quite a bit of revenue
and it comes in through a revenue share
agreement with Google on search traffic
and so these days is you have more and
more of these kind of network based
businesses there's more of a revenue
dreams that come from being able to
basically refer you know referral
businesses and so I think the business
models actually goes exactly what we're
talking about with the network the apps
on the network it's it's actually not
just charging the user for money it's
what is the user doing and then what
other businesses want to basically get
in the middle of that in some way and so
the business model creativity that we're
seeing now is a lot more advanced than
what we used to have we have a question
coming in from Twitter which is a
carries on on that about the carrier's
business models you know obviously the
the with fixed-line the carriers are
pretty much the dumb pipe we don't look
to Comcast for app stores with Wireless
they still want value-added services and
their own business model is still built
around more than simple transmission how
do you think this is going to evolve
I think that's changed a great deal
already in the last few years I mean I
you know it used to be look I mean the
valley the valley is littered with the
corpses of mobile software startups you
know basically between 1995 and
basically what 2006 through 2007 it
because it used to be if you wanted to
start a new mobile app company used to
be very first thing to do is go to
carrier and see if you can cut the deal
that would get you on the deck right to
the term right the deck was to get you
on the default screen on the motorola
startac or whatever the phone was at the
time and that was after you had figured
out how to use brew or Java or whatever
to build a local app and you would try
to figure out all the phone
compatibility issues and just the
complete nightmare of what you had to
deal with you had to cut the deal with
the carrier and then you had to give up
you know 40 percent your company there's
been a year and a half negotiating that
or whatever it was you know these days I
mean it's already so different right
because with the both both with iPhone
and with Android you know the App Store
is provided by Apple or Google right now
by the carrier in most cases you know
you can run whatever Apple you know you
want on it as the developer the app you
don't need information from the carriers
and so I actually think that change has
already happened so you think they are
dumb pipes well I don't know if they say
dumb pipes I think they have a lot of
opportunity to do all kinds of things in
the network that are gonna be very
interesting I think there's
opportunities to add value but I think
that the sort of chokehold that used to
exist that you know for a long time
choked off innovation I think that's
gone would you say that the mr. Comcast
you know fixed line experience is
predicative of how it's gonna play and
well even that's evolving and so Comcast
as an example so Comcast example so
comcast comcast about me this thing got
this new thing Xfinity
TV Everywhere right so they're actually
developing this thing we're basically
there they're there they're taking
they're actually decoupling their
software from the network and they're
making it possible to receive all the
Comcast programming and all the
value-added services like pay TV and all
the e-commerce things are doing
everything on any device right and so
they're already like jumping into the
new world actually Comcast in particular
jumping in with with with with both feet
and so I think it's changing its
changing very fast now there was a very
long time where this was a very big
issue I think that's really changed good
let me take another question from the
audience in the back please yeah hello
my name is Aaron Landy I actually have a
question for Chris Anderson yeah sorry
about that mark yeah so Chris I was
actually wondering where the the spectra
of the magazine publishing industry is
gone I mean everything is turning
graphical right now but like as news is
like getting bigger on the internet with
news dot me and all top I Guy Kawasaki I
was wondering where you see like the
actual print magazines going uh I'll be
brief I sew magazines obviously are
different than newspapers and and and
and beyond
they tend to be periodicals obviously
the tablet has been the real
game-changer we'll talk more about this
actually later today with chanson and
Ryan from Adobe but the tablet has been
the the the first media platform that
came with an e-commerce engine attached
one of the big problems with with paid
media is that in the early days there
was no easy way to pay for me to even
people wanted to they could they
couldn't do it the the the notion of the
the iPad and and other tablets having
that sort of you know built-in
relationship billing relationship with
that with Apple or Google makes it a
one-click and I'm experienced that takes
a lot of the friction out of the choice
of a buying plus it's a it's a rich
medium and so it's it's clearly
differentiated from the web and
therefore can-can you can argue is worth
paying for so I think the future is is
this thing and you know three years into
it so far so good do you are you
investing in you know tablet media in
any way not yeah a little bit outside of
our zone I will say I agree with you
thing which is one of the big one of the
big mistakes I've talked about this one
of the big mistakes one of the things I
wish we could go back in time and fix
this we should have built payments into
the browser yeah if we had built
payments the the counterfactual
alternate alternate history I like
playing with is what if payments had
been built in the browser one-click
payments for the very beginning starting
in 92
what's that who would have owned that
would you have been a bank well that's
that was actually the big part of the
problem is it was actually essentially
impossible to do because there was no
like the credit card companies had and
try we tried we tried we went out and
talked to the credit card companies the
banks it was impossible at that point I
think to work our way we actually
weren't able to do it all so Microsoft
wasn't able to do it yeah how hard it
was because we both tried so it was it
was it was very difficult it actually
took paypal in a lot of ways to kind of
open everything up but that you know
happen years later but you know I think
the web it's very interesting right the
web would have turned out very
differently in some ways I think much
better because he would have had for
example you know you would have had
business models involved maybe in a much
healthier way in a lot of cases for a
lot of industries on the other hand you
know maybe you would have lost a lot
maybe you would have lost a lot of the
free content and free services and all
the free you know I had based business
models and people come up with so it's
hard to say but I would like to try that
experiment over again something well
there's a huge amount of innovation as
you know going on in transactions with
Square and and and beyond mobile mobile
payments etc are you are you focusing on
that yeah that's something well number
one I mean we are mmmm on ebay board so
we're working on that very hard with
PayPal and you know so that's you know
that's one and then two it's getting
very interesting to see what the new
business models you make payments really
easy I've always been a I've always been
a believer that it's not so much that
people don't want to pay for things like
content for example it's that if it's if
it's complicated then they just like
it's just it's easier not to then they
want exactly and so so much of this has
to do with convenience and one-click
I think people generally will pay for
things that they find interesting
valuable entertaining and I think we're
gonna start we're now able to run that
experiment in a different way now that
we're getting payments built more into
the tablets the phones into PayPal there
are paypal being built into more things
Square so forth so it's more about the
ease and psychology of payment rather
than the price itself yeah so much more
like I've always thought the privacy
problem but the piracy problem was
always overblown yeah it's not that you
know there's not that there's 300
million people who want to go pirate
content and like commit crimes it's that
if you don't let me get my digital
content in a way that's easy to get I'm
gonna go find a way to get it
and
and I think you know media industry is
now adjusting I mean who lose been I
think a pretty big success and it's an
example of like it can I should be done
right yeah we have one more question
which I'll take from from the the
Twitter audience it's actually built on
something we talked about in our in our
in our Q&A in the magazine which is
Silicon Valley as is our return
alternatives to Silicon Valley as a
global Innovation Center and you have
this concept of you know where are the
campuses you use this expression the big
campuses can you talk a little bit about
your based in Silicon Valley most of
your investments or are local
can you everyone wants to be a Silicon
Valley can they I would love for there
to be twenty or a hundred or a thousand
Silicon Valley's I think it would be
tremendous I'm I try to live in the
world in which that was the case I think
the formula is actually fairly
straightforward and I think it seems to
be for some reason it's hard to
replicate so right you need outstanding
research universities right which
there's just aren't that many in the
world and a lot of them are in the US
and we just need more of those all over
the world you need the graduates out of
those research universities entering a
culture and an environment where
risk-taking and starting companies is an
accepted thing to do I mean the valley
it's encouraged everywhere else you know
it's either accepted or frowned upon and
so you need a much more risk oriented
culture than exists in a lot of places
both elsewhere in this country and in
the world
then you need liquid and deep capital
markets you need well-functioning
capital markets because you do have to
actually fund these things and so you
actually do need venture capital and you
actually do need the stock market and
things like that and in a you know not
non corrupt banking systems and and then
you need rule of law you need contract
law
you need the ability to actually like
you know sign a contract with somebody
and actually not have them just steal
all your money a year later and it is
shocking how few places on the planet
are able to combine all four of those
things and I don't want to like you know
I want to dump in any particular country
but like it's very hard to go around the
world and find any place other than the
US and place other than Silicon Valley
that combines all four of those things
and the big cultural question I think of
our time is going to be you know which
countries which cities which cultures
which societies are going to be willing
to really put this formula together to
try to do this and try to do it right
we're here in New York yeah and New York
New York is a great like the risk-taking
culture in New York is way advanced I
think in the last 20 years like I think
it's very promising what's happening in
New York there's still a problem that
research universities the the new
Cornell campus you know of course it's
gonna take 20 years
to build that that will be a huge
advance you know because Columbia and NY
you know New York University are great
universities but they're not large-scale
research universities like Stanford or
Berkeley hopefully Cornell will fill
that in so you're starting to see you're
definitely starting to see the
phenomenon but it just you my attitude
is there to the throttle needs to be
come forward and all four of those
factors to actually have the result be
the kind of catalytic effect that we see
in the belly and you're finding your own
investments increasingly turning to New
York or no we're roughly I would say
we're roughly 80 well we're a single
office firm so we're but do we think
that your capital is a boutique business
not a not a scale business and so we're
a we're a single office for a memo park
so we're definitely biased or provincial
if you will we're maybe 80% invested in
the US and then within that 80% of that
in the valley it's roughly the breakdown
so we'll go outside the valley for
extraordinary companies the challenge
was growing us in venture capital going
outside the valley is there's just it's
hard to find the places where there's
ten things it's easy to find the place
where there's you know you can go to
Ottawa and there's one you can go to
Seattle and there's two or three you can
go to Salt Lake City and there's you
know two or three but it's hard to find
the place where there's ten a hundred a
thousand of these sort of really vital
young businesses with the level of
creativity that we look for New York is
starting to be one of those places and I
think it's very encouraging what's
what's been happening here increasingly
active here so when when andreessen
horowitz opens its satellite office in
new york we know that the the time will
have come that's right please do I mean
thanking mark entries okay thank you
everybody